justin donny is on the mound today for
the seattle mariners and the 24 year old
right-hander makes his ninth start
justin dunn he had a 7.80 era through
his first four starts of the season but
don recently 2-0 with a 1-3-5 his last
four starts
he does have command issues 25 walks
you see it right there in 35 innings
they've got to be patient at the plate
one out and here is fernando tatis jr
breaking ball swinging a fly ball into
deep center field lewis going back
reaches up on the run and he makes the
catch holy smokes what a grab by kyle
lewis
on the run sprinting back toward the
wall in center field he hit the winning
track he had to take a flying leap on
the run to haul it in what a catch by
kyle lewis that young man covers a lot
of ground in a hurry paul making his
11th start 28 year old nelson lamet
sliders and strikeouts that's been the
theme this season
you see the 3-1 record opponent's only
hitting 171. he does have that wipeout
slider two outs in the first kyle lewis
in scoring position at second base here
for the ends
2-2 ground ball right side kronerworth
two is left
that wild pitch meant nothing pounding
his glove man with his uh pitching hand
then nelson lynette now two men in
scoring position for hospital and hosmer
deliver as he stands in old for one in
this game swaying and a miss struck him
out dunn turns around and flexes there
as well he should gets out of a big spot
stranded and again another runner in
scoring position with two down breaking
ball swing and a miss for strike three
justin dunn with his third strike out of
the afternoon and he gets cronenworth
with an excellent curveball and that's
it for the padres so two down kyle
singer here's seeger and a check swing
roller to the left side fernando the
only guy there it went right to him how
about dueling no-no's on this september
20th to the fifth no score grisham has
walked and he's also grounded out to
moore in the dirt but a swing and a miss
by grisham for strike three what a pitch
by dunn what an afternoon in san diego
for justin dunn two down seven in a row
retired by lumet swinging a ground ball
through the left side for a base hit so
there's the first base hit of the
afternoon evan white a hard hit ground
ball right in between machado and tatis
through the left side of the infield and
the mariners have the first hit of the
game and it comes here in the bottom of
the fifth inning with two outs tim lopes
right here eight hitter right-handed
batter swinging a ground ball down the
third base line a fair ball all the way
in toward the corner white rounded
second heading for third up with the
ball is pro far in the corner and white
falls down now he picks himself up heads
home the throw is cut off the relay to
the plate not in time white around third
blew out a tire fell down he was able to
get up pick himself up and score on the
play for a guy who doesn't throw that
hard you can still label him is kind of
effectively wild look out tatis goes
down again first pitch kind of missed
there by justin dunn 2-1 pitch here to
tate look at that one up and in there's
no recent history here but two at the
noggin believes sure dunn is not trying
to to hit tatis this is the one out
runner and that is the timing run at
first base breaking ball swung on hit
the left field standing in the yard
marimo going back it bounces on the
track and into the seats and that is the
first hit of the afternoon off of justin
dunn second and third still one-nothing
mariners here's will myers myers looks
this in the air to center field kyle
lewis going back at the wall it's gonna
carry out of here a three-run home run
for will myers puts the padres on top
three to one what a comeback year for
will myers if somebody else is the
comeback player in the national league i
don't know exactly who he might be so
from the no hitbid
to a two-run deficit and the end of the
outing for dunn two out there's kyle
lewis straight free call cranks out the
side in the sixth ten strikeouts he
threw 86 pitches 65 of which were
strikes didn't give up a hit until there
were two outs in the fit and now a
couple of strikeouts to pair with those
two walks here in the bottom of the
seventh inning two away with tim lopes
coming up and a pop-up right side of the
infield moreland crossing over into foul
territory fighting the sun a little bit
he's got room he makes the catch and the
inning is over padres are six outs away
from the postseason one on and the
better will be dylan moore swinging a
well-hit ball deep to left field pro far
going back and this one is gone goodbye
baseball dylan moore ties it up here in
the bottom of the eighth inning it's the
mariners three the padres three dylan
moore's eighth home run of the year and
this is a line shot
into the lower deck and left here at
petco park and the winning run in
scoring position ground ball to t to his
left with the grab and a throw bang bang
play it first out at first base yes it
will be extra innings high drama in san
diego go ahead run 90 feet away for the
padres fernando oh for three with a walk
and a stolen base in this game two for
eleven in the series in the air to
center field falling fast that's going
to get in for a base hit mateo scores
from third of the padres take a 4-3 lead
in the top of the 10th tatis puts the
padres on top 4-3
now the infield in all the way around
for san diego j.p crawford five ball
straight away left field pro far makes
the catch here's the throw here comes
lopes coming home lopes head first dive
he's in there safely we got a new ball
game at 4-4
double in the sixth inning a one for
four day fly ball
headed down the left field line and
falling but heading over it'll fall fair
here comes machado he's gonna try and
score the throw to the play will be late
and machado is
[Applause]
at third across the diamond is nola at
first 2-2 pitch profile will light it
into center field for a base head from
third comes moreland
nola stops at second and the padres have
a 6-4 lead they get a second run here at
the top of the 11th inning two down in
the 11th and trent grisham grisham will
send this into the shift and it's
knocked down noah's gonna come around
and try and score through the plane will
be late padres will take a 7-4 lead
they got three runs at the top of the
alignment two down a count of owen two
swinging a mess he struck him out for
the first time in 14 years the san diego
padres have clinched their spot in the
postseason
[Applause]